reports are coming in of a key political
development in Afghanistan president
Ashraf Ghani and his rival Abdullah
Abdullah have ended months of crisis by
agreeing to share power Abdullah had
refused to accept Ghana's victory in
last September's presidential election
observers feared their failure to
resolve their standoff was endangering
plans for a peace deal with the Taliban
[Applause]
let's meet now to journalist Ali Latifi
in Kabul Ali some positive news just
bring us up to speed on this
announcement what's been agreed on sure
so the news is basically that you know
there is no political agreement which
will see dr. Abdullah given the role of
essentially leading all of us on asan's
peace efforts and getting to appoint
officials in terms of that kind of a
portfolio but he also will get to
appoint cabinet positions up to 50% of
the cabinet so it really is much more
akin to some kind of a power-sharing
deal than the previous deal they had
from 2014 to 2019 in which dr. Abdullah
held the role of chief executive but
didn't necessarily get the exact rights
enshrined in this sort of an agreement
where it stated specifically that he
gets to choose up to 50 percent of the
cabinet are they only last week we saw
two appalling attacks including one on a
maternity ward emotions must be raw
is there a hope that today's
announcement will bring us a step closer
to ending that sort of violence I don't
know if it will necessarily and that
kind of violence because that kind of
vile mean in terms of the attack on the
maternity ward we still don't know who
did it no group has claimed
responsibility for the attack but the
thing about this agreement is that you
know in the beginning in the initial
days and months after the September
election people who voted for either
dropped out of any or dr. Abdullah were
very adamant that their katadyn
candidate not only won but that there
would be no agreement there would be no
deal
and as the months have gone on we've
seen that obviously there is a deal and
that people essentially at this point
they just want it done they're just
hoping that there's some kind of a
resolution to it and that they can move
on they no longer have that adamant
faith that their candidate will stand by
you know what they promise that they
won't make any deals that they that they
will lead the way they want to and now
it's just sort of a sense of resignation
you know that this is just the way
things are and given that where does
that leave the intra Afghan pay Stokes
so this will hopefully pave the way for
for actually working towards the intra
Avalon peace talks because now we know
specifically that dr. Abdullah's entire
mandate will be peace and he's been very
Pro peace and very adamant about peace
even since the election during the
election he had said that he would give
up his candidacy if there was real
developments towards peace at that time
which obviously didn't happen then you
know the Taliban and the u.s. didn't
come to their agreement until February
but so hopefully this will and all of
those disagreements and and these two
leaders can come together and appoint
their specific teams to go and negotiate
with the Taliban at some point likely in
Germany or Norway a limit if he's
speaking to us from the Afghan capital
Kabul thank you thank you